طبعا اليوم هو ثالث يوم في المونديال لكن
هو اليوم الاول واليوم الصعب واليوم
الحقيقي للمتابع السعودي والمتابعه ايضا
الخليجي بعد بدايه المنتخب القطري للقاء
المنتخب السعودي مع المنتخب الارجنتيني
لقاء كبير جدا لقاء منتظر لقاء صعب قوي في
اول ايام هذه التصفيات النهائيه او
اختبارات مونديال قطر حدود سيلاقي المنتخب
السعودي في واحد ظهرا المنتخب الارجنتيني
الاستعدادات وتمت بالامس ست ايضا الجمهور
السعودي توافق بكثافه يعني الى فجر اليوم
الجمهور السعوديه توافق يقدر العدد اللي
وصل حتى الان ما بين
13,000 او 14,000 مشجع سعودي الاحتلال
التامه همم شاهدته الجمهور السعودي يتجه
الوسيله اللي يبعد عننا تقريبا مسافه كيلو
ونصف تقريبا لم يفتح الباب حتى الان كل
الجماهير هذا شهاده الجمهور الارجنتيني
اللي همم اعتقد انه الاكثر بعد الجماهير
خليجيه يتواجد في الدعم من خلال متابعتي
مباراه منتظره مباراه صعبه لكن ان شاء
الله الاخضر قدها هذا عودنا يعني بالذات
في 94 كانت البدايه امام منتخب كبير مرشح
منتخب الهولندي وفاز بصعوبه مشرف اتمنى ان
نكرر نفس الانجاز اليوم امام الارجنتين من
خلال الفيديوهات
الخبره والثقه وحتى في الجمهور الحاضر من
قبل المنتخب السعودي هل في فعاليات على
هامش المباراه مثلا في الدوحه تحدثنا عنها
تجمع للسعوديين هنا وهناك
نعم نعم المجلس الجمهور الرسمي بالاضافه
الى وزاره الرياضه راح تقيم مسيره قبل
المباراه مسيره رسميه للجمهور السعودي
بازيائه وباعلامه تنقل للحماس
للاعب تنقل الحماس ايضا والثقه في المشجع
لتشجيع فريقه طوال 90 دقيقه مسير رسميه
راح تكون بالاعلام ان شاء الله رح ننقل
لكم كل التفاصيل للجمهور في نهايه
البرنامج ان شاء الله من داخل الملعب بعد
فتح الابواب ان شاء الله راح يكون دعم
رسمي امس ايضا كان في البيت السعودي زياره
مفاجاه لوزير الرياضه اسمه الامير عبد
العزيز بن تركي
شده من المشجع السعودي رفع وتيره حماس
واللي سبقت ايضا من خلال الخطوه الاولى من
لقاء الامير محمد بن سلمان بالمنتخب
السعودي اللي وجه رساله كبيره رساله عظيمه
بانه استمتعوا قدموا اللي عليكم ونتيجه
يعني في حكم القضاء والقدر لكن اليوم مشجع
سعودي جدا متحمس من يومين من بدايه توفت
بشجع سعودي وهو متحمس ان شاء الله انه تصل
الرساله للاعب وللجهاز الفني لتقديم
المستوى المرضي اللي ننتظره من الاخضر
السعودي امام الكبير منتخب العراق
يبدا ثالث ايام المونديال واللقاء المرتب
بين السعوديه والارجنتين والكل ينتظر هذه
المباراه حدثنا عن التحضيرات داخل الملعب
امم
طبعا الملعب ااا اللي بيحضر له ميزه اخرى
غير انه يتابع لمباراه كاس العالم ملعب
هذا نهايه كاس العالم ما راح يكون شيء
اسمه استاذ لوسين راح يتحول الى الخدمه
مجتمعيه مطاعم مراكز حكوميه مازارات متاحف
فهذا فرصه كبيره اللي يحضر انت حاضر
السعوديه والارجنتين او لقاء اخر طبعا
ايضا اختير هذا الملعب الجميل اللي يقع
شمال الدوحه على مسافه 23 كيلو شمال
الدوحه ملعب جميل جدا ان شاء الله راح
نقول لكم تفاصيلها الملعب في نهايه النشره
همم في نهايه برنامج صباح العربيه ملعب
رائع ملعب يعني تجلس كل همم جميل في
فعاليات طبعا للجمهور من بدايه اصوله حتى
الدخول في ايفنتات في اماكن الجلوس وايضا
اللي جايين بدري اماكن للافطار في فعاليات
ضمن
اللجنه المنظمه لكاس العالم راح يستمتع
فيها المشجع وراح يستمت ايضا فيها المشاهد
خلف شاشات التلفزيون ملعب جميل جدا اعتقد
انه راح يكون من اعظم المزارات بعد كاس
العالم وهو
يعني اختير في نهايه اول مباراه النهائيه
لكاس العالم ان شاء الله وفهد منشير انه
انت رح تكون معنا في الساعه الثانيه من
صباح العربيه ونذكر بانه مباراه اليوم
معكم
من داخل الملعب باذن الله اوكي ومباراه
اليوم من ذكر كمان انه بين الارجنتين
والسعوديه ستكون الساعه 12 بتوقيت مكه
بالانتظار ايضا الواحده بتوقيت قطر شكرا
لك من الدوحه مراسل صباح العربيه تحت
الشهريه